I cannot see but I can hear the world
around me meet Brian he's known as the
world's best totally blind mountain
biker when I was younger I had
functional vision and I played sports I
had dreams of becoming a professional
athlete and then suddenly when he was 14
he completely lost his sight over the
course of 3 months his optic nerves
inexplicably failed and all he could see
was darkness he wasn't able to bike ride
or participate in the sports he once
enjoyed I couldn't play hockey I had to
stop rollerblading couldn't read the
classroom board anymore my world had
shrunk he had to find a new way to
navigate the world he found his cane
limiting but when he learned to make a
tongue click his world changed again for
the better and it wasn't long until he
ventured back outdoors
I really missed bike riding and I really
wanted to be active I just didn't know
how to do it as a blind rider it was a
goal for me to get off the tandem and
have the experience of being able to
pilot my own bike it all starts with a
zip tie a sighted person would attaches
to their frame and angle it into the
bike wheel the bike wheel would make
noise and a sound to follow while we
would still have to be click eventually
Brian was able to mountain bike alone
and without the zip tie when I'm riding
my bike down a mountain it's the same
thing bats are using echolocation I can
make my active sonar signal by making a
tongue click I start off with trying to
find the object furthest in the distance
and then peace the world together with
things closer and closer Brian has to
enter an almost meditative state and
remain extremely focused everything has
to leave my brain and those sounds are
painting a picture in my head
a vivid world of acoustic images he
didn't keep his passion to himself
though he's helped teach over thousands
of people to hear their world a little
bigger this is a teachable thing anybody
can do this and I'm happy to show them
riding my bike was something I never
thought I'd be able to do again and now
that I'm doing it it serves as a great
example to challenge preconceived ideas
you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen this is the
thousand hand bot hit stop the dance
pretty cool huh one would think that a
performance this difficult and precise
would require all five senses we'll
think again because all these dancers
can't hear the music making this
performance even cooler
[Music]
founded in 1987 the China disabled
people's performing art troupe performs
eloquent dances plays and operas the
music is performed by the visually
impaired and the dance numbers are
performed by those hard of hearing the
thousand Han Bodhisattva dance is the
troops most popular performance it was
also one of the most difficult dances
for them to learn and that's where Chun
Tian comes in she and other instructors
use sign language to help conduct the
dancers white camp I sold practicing the
dollar
what should a military war child or
national under-20 value Bangkok
Mountain an idea what you've done for
Jindal yeah again we didn't shoot down
hundreds in silence for example Tim
Boucher you can Leon handsome I'm coming
up you may come here there's a whole
time ago school total funds on three
each of the Kanawha then show you a
really nice I mean you know without so
say one ends down down hammering down a
civilian to young people so tell my
teacher they also realize that spending
time together off stage would not only
enhance their friendship but their
performance on stage as well
[Music]
in bings case he and other musicians
developed their own technique for
playing without being able to see Roman
CVO khulafa food la jolla CA santee
Savile Row where eche coalition sang ho
de pusi time before time ago a chill
written on a rant idea young children
Cointreau
boochi boochi - AHA no Mogambo to attach
oh hi Oh si ans angle for don't usually
many innovations people Kyoto Bhagwad
Gita
oh man one zillion can follow Chi GI
Pecha Kucha modular Joshua Salomon
Sangha young fool equation true non
woven and on see a more Tommy the year
monkey be a descendant of koli-shakya
the station homogeneous insular and work
in Hammond that wishes since in order
shortage here for me that GCSE on
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
para para nice kujaku sonidos I have a
cat in Antonio's muy bonitas
let's have a cat in Antonio me simply
show local sir CA go this route Allah
sorry thought Reforma Sonia lisara miss
la forma con la que tengo the appreciate
a mini mi nombre home below collazo yas
a Catorce A&E okay registro lawsonia
Herren at Raleigh's choice ago Dennis in
en tow lo único que puede ver son loses
mi mundo son sonidos s todo todo tipo de
información que reciben premia lugar es
ahora
Belloc pastor of our amis couch Isuzu
Nero's Palace in Pajaro cantando condo
kudos on your Emmy entender social
Australian economy no me hace falta no
Maria fault Avalos paura mia el sonido
de la Salle's musical antonio inventive
a dinosaur not a musical vienna fallacy
de manera en un canto muy muy strident
SE puede cuchara gran doed Estancia no
después el taro con su sonido Moo's
vamos ok taro taro taro todo el tiempo
[Music]
con Tomas my load eCos que podemos tener
Y case else or Sol Sol Sol tiene un
silver que trae Mucha pas la importancia
de registrar la sabes gusta meant a lock
on survey she owned el trabajo que a
really soda capped REO veget rawr los
sonidos de la sabes s tambien parte de
nuestro patrimonio natural lamentable
meant al ser humano lowest extrusion
entonces para mi grab our cada sonido en
un lugar de Tinto honest como tener UN
registro
es como dare a un para cito a lugar
[Music]
[Music]
football is the most popular sport in
Sierra Leone and in the city of Freetown
there is one very special team meet the
Flying Stars my name nawa medal Appiah
how to play for Sun roof line strategy
football club Mohammed grew up playing
football but when he was only 10 years
old he stepped on a landmine and had to
have his right leg amputated and
unfortunately Muhammad isn't alone the
saloon flanks the amputee football team
now war affected amplitude bladder so so
did every member of the Flying Stars has
lost limbs as a result of the violence
that occurred during the civil war in
Sierra Leone but the players don't let
their injuries stop them from getting
into the game then coaches ready jump
the roof then the blue one foots one leg
vitally mean the coach for the Flying
Star amputee football club presently in
a free toy a touchy pleasure
well Valley oval Adrienne Fulton we
gonna film 12 video well Galloway - okay
country welcome the walk in put gas on
trend give will a woody do Ln short
shorts to Ornish desert and shorty
clunky penalty shoot-out until at 70
normal act out the Ebola River
well church church
not only is it a competitive sport it is
helping them cope with their injuries
and overcome the stigma that's
associated with the disabled what is
this discrimination artist - country
offensive we need for do some ceramic to
forgive a problem in what better way
then football college football
especially amputee football nine
children life and I'm a Canadian ostrich
habibika the lure of college but not
only men compete we are end
[Music]
you